this list proves that you can have such
a vibrant and fulfilling career
at 50 at 60 at 70 even at 80 and beyond
our chief content officer randall lane
was talking with mika brzezinski the
co-host of morning joe and founder of
know your value
and in that conversation the concept of
50 over 50
emerged this is a list highlighting
women who achieve success later in life
they're shattering gender norms but
they're also shattering age norms
ageism is one of the things that we
don't talk about too much but it affects
everyone it does affect all genders
but particularly women it's the first
time we've ever done this list
we really want to make a statement that
women over the age of 50 are stepping
into their power and changing the world
mika brzezinski
co-produced this list with us and points
out that this list is only women
because men have their 50 over 50 lists
they
have the business roundtable they have
the top spots at s p
500 companies we've seen lists of men
it's time to see a list of women
the 50 over 50 came together through a
number of ways we opened up nominations
to the general public and we received
10 000 nominations for this list of 50
people
of the 10 2500 were identified as
semi-finalists
they answered a bunch of questions from
us
and then from those answers we
determined our finalists i spoke to
sources
editors spoke to their sources i spoke
to other editors at forbes
we had a huge help from forbes staff it
feels like everyone has worked on this
project
it is i think against the ethos of the
list to say
that one story is better than another so
the list is alphabetical
i'll start with aisha evans she is the
ceo of zusk it's an automated taxi
startup like a robotic taxi company
she is 52 years old she had worked at
intel for over a decade for 12 years
and she went from a very secure job at
at intel to then be the ceo
of this automated taxi startup she's an
immigrant from senegal she talks about
how most ceos in silicon valley don't
look like her
and it's just an incredible incredible
story
janet ivanovic is 78 years old you
likely know her from seeing her books on
the bestseller list but what you may not
know about her career is
the bulk of it happened over 50. she was
writing romance novels in her 40s
and she was doing okay but then she
switched to crime
she started her stephanie plum series
and
it hit the best seller list and she
started that series when she was 51.
today her book advances are north of
seven figures
and she has had more than 40 titles on
the new york times bestseller list
i also really like the story of teresa
hodge she's 58 years old she's the
founder of
two companies mission launch and r3
score
her story is interesting at 44 years old
she was
found guilty of male fraud and sentenced
to prison
she served 70 months before being
released and in 2017
she had been out for a little bit she
co-founded our three score with her
daughter it's an alternative background
check
she wants to help people like her who
have been incarcerated but want to start
their life anew
and mission launch is her social
entrepreneurship venture
and it's part of this list that's really
important to us is
are you paying it forward you've had
your career you've had your life what
are you doing to make life better
for the next generation and i think you
can argue that companies like mission
launch and r3 score are attempting to do
just that
some people in our audience might
recognize this next name esther perel
she is 62 she's a psychotherapist an
author a podcast host the preeminent
expert
on sexual health and relationship advice
she has been running a therapy practice
for more than 35 years
so it's not like she's new to this but
in 2017 the publishing of her book the
state of affairs
and the launch of her podcast where
should we begin took her career to the
next level
she has had three ted talks and they
have done more than 30 million views
i know many of you watching listen to
her i know i certainly do
we were so so fortunate to get
a few minutes with kim ing she is the
general manager of the miami marlins now
i'm a phillies fan but i love her story
because it shows persistence she wrote
her college thesis on title ix
immediately began working in baseball
she interned at the chicago white sox
she worked at the new york yankees she
was qualified for a general manager job
well before she was 50. she told us that
she had over the course of 15 years
10 interviews for the general manager
job she was turned down
but in 2020 at 52
she became the general manager of the
miami marlins she finally did it so it
shows
just never never give up to my
accounting this is the first time we
have done
four solo covers only featuring women
on our covers are shonda runs
the iconic producer shondaland founder
vice president kamala harris
real real founder and ceo julie
wainwright
and arc invest founder kathy wood
these are powerful women across major
sectors of the american economy
if you don't see a name of a woman that
you think is powerful or deserving of
being over the 50 over 50 that doesn't
mean that they're not awesome that
they're not achieving great things
we were just rigorous and looking for
the breakthroughs
the i'm over 50 and this has never
happened to me before
this has never happened in history
before when you turn
50 you don't disappear and if anything
what
interviews with these women are proving
to me is they
feel more free than ever before
[Music]
you